[Music]
hi
uh dan mace uh this is casey neistat
and this is my application video to be
your intern
not sure if you remember me but actually
back like a while ago we did some work
together
as far as my qualifications go well i've
made um
youtube videos now i do realize that
your new company is located in cape town
south africa and you say the word and
all why they're i'm willing to do
whatever it takes then to get that
internship
so please consider casey to be your new
[Music]
intern
okay not an oblique note but on a
serious note
i've been feeling increasingly unsure of
my body
and this isn't some sort of search for
affirmation in the comments to go
hey dan you're looking great don't worry
or whatever
i'm not sad so don't worry about me if
your fingers were on the keyboard
ready to write something like that some
form of affirmation
thank you though the the world really
needs more people like you
but this isn't about that ever since
lockdown i've been sitting in this
office
editing all day eating absolute [ __ ]
and just can't find the motivation to
exercise but daily
i see gabs who somehow has the ability
to stay fit and
have this incredibly flawless body this
isn't a shallow based assumption that
she won't love me anymore if my blob
grew even bigger it's rather
i don't know it's something i want to do
get fit again
when i searched how to get a six-pack
fast this device popped up
look at these buds and look what's just
arrived
[Music]
huh
full intensity so only where to send it
let's go oh
jesus i guess i had to go through
the pain to remind me of a very valuable
live lesson that there's no shortcut
to success or a six-pack my new plan is
this
art with the old invisibility
is that recording yeah why are you
planning on just
getting new to work i am filming but
that doesn't take away from the
seriousness of this
i have decided to go full health
[Music]
vegetables
[Music]
that's actually pretty good what is that
[Music]
gaps what are you seriously trying to
brand this vlog
what is this
and speaking about doing brand deals
with integrity and
not pulling up gabs over there this
video is brought to you by my friends at
storyblocks
the stock library for audio video and
graphics it's a seamless process between
us
because i use this site all the time and
even gabs made use of one of their
stocks to
put a palm tree behind her there but
more on that later
gabs even though the smoothie was
delicious i've realized
the vegetable root just isn't for me
however the overly keen intern
casey that you saw earlier seemed to be
a really
fit guy so i'm gonna try one last thing
give him a call
what's up you look sad i am sad
i'm feeling like i'm turning into a blob
yeah i got one piece of advice
run [ __ ] run
baby can you come fetch me please
what are you doing i'm getting fit like
i told you
i'm feeling like like a blob i love you
and everything about
you so you
love me but i do have a blog okay
forget the whole whole thing for now and
on a more
exciting no that's not a big enough word
in thrilling
engrossing moments of ecstasy
on a more synonym for inspiring notes
i just got these keys these are the keys
to my new creative factory
studio type space i haven't really
figured out a name for it yet but i'm
sure you'd understand
how ironic it would be if i named it
after it's numbering
on the main road 370 on the main road
coincidental upgrade from 368. let's see
[Applause]
[Music]
i've made the decision to rather show
you the entire space
in next week's vlog why well in all
honesty
i i feel like the space is so epic and i
tend to
to get distracted with so many different
by the way i actually just want to show
you where
i'm right now i'm not in that space i'm
actually in the most
makeshift sound booth in my garage
working on
a really big ad like a really really
big ad this is a good time to point out
that
even though i am going full time on
youtube i still do
direct the odd purpose-driven tv
commercial
but where was i oh yeah the factory
space
it's an exciting part of a bigger vision
i've had for a long time
my youtube videos the ads i decide to
take on
are all part of that vision visions this
week's tattoo story
so a long long time ago in a galaxy far
far wait what am i saying remember when
we had television sets
i was always transfixed by the idea that
some channels were static
nothing on them just black and white
static pixels while others had
colorful moving pictures that's what i
believe makes up the vision
in tailored vision i guess like someone
had
the vision to manufacture those
meaningless black and white pixels
into something with meaning and color
ever since i can remember i've always
wanted to make films and
i felt like one of those static channels
would one day be
my moving pictures and around five or
six years ago
it came to life a couple of mates and i
made a self-funded film
with no expectations that a friend
suggested i entered into khan
and i ended up winning the young
directors award
two actually one was for another
documentary i'd made a year prior
but after that i got my first
commercials board then i did some more
commercials
then i started to take my vision onto
youtube which i'm still really in the
process of figuring out but it's the
same kind of static
you know the channels are already there
and you can apply your vision
and make the [ __ ] that makes you happy
and maybe even the people that watch it
too
so i got a tattoo to my arm a forever
visual reminder that
everything in life starts as static
i've seen a lot of comments asking about
how i achieve this motion scrapbooking
feel
in these tattoo stories it doesn't take
as much creativity
as it does time it all happens here in
my garage i'm not going to explain the
technicalities
we'll say that for another time but the
thing is i definitely
don't do it alone i have two helpers
one being tristan who sits here
literally
all night long just cutting cutting
cutting and making
an extreme mess and the other being my
homies
at storyblocks the sponsor of today's
vlog and take this from me
just such a great way to speed up your
creative process their site really does
have the highest quality
stocks footage textures illustrations
everything you need to do what you do
best or essentially
to tell a story in the most
aesthetically pleasing manner for my
immersion scrapbooking segments
i make use of storyblocks it's really
helpful like in the
tattoo story that you just saw with an
unlimited library with one million
assets strong
all yours to download and use everywhere
you bound to find what you need with
their unlimited all access
subscription plan so go ahead and click
the link in the description to sign up
today
wait i've got something super funny to
show you
a couple of weeks ago i put out an ad
for new intern and
besides casey's epic video entry
i interviewed a bunch of applicants over
zoom and
partly as as a prank as well as a good
guide to test the moral compass
i did this would you would you call
yourself someone
that's that's willing to go the extra
mile
to make it happen yeah absolutely man
i mean i'm down for anything else
obviously
cooking medicines how would i say this
have you seen breaking bad
yeah yeah i've seen it yeah
yeah yeah in order to
produce additional cash to be able to
make this feature film that i want to
make
would you be willing to do a few
deliveries
um every week say three times a week you
want me to
deliver math for you like telling me
i i i guess
no i'm sorry i mean yeah if that's what
the job entails i guess that's what the
job entails eh
i i'm down for anything no
it's covet 19 and i need the money are
you running a um
are you running a medler well i think
you're telling me like
i can't really do that man dude i'm
joking
thank god i was like
slowly put that together i thought this
is a youtube video for a second so i'm
like
and getting a new intern would give me
more time to
exercise all right i thank you perfect
on that note that concludes this vlog i
hope you enjoyed it and
if you want to join the brew community
please click the subscribe button yep
baby you have to be more assertive
to tell them subscribe to this channel
click on the subscribe button and put on
your notification bell
okay i get it i get it good job
subscribe if you've done so thank you
and
remember to put on your notification
bell other than that you're awesome bru
and
i'll see you next week
[Music]
you